[Musik]
[Applaus]
danke dass noch viel zeit hat er
wahrscheinlich im ersten wird in wien
apa - sowie drei formate ersten stücks
das heißt ich habe schöne dreieinhalb
sekunden abgenommen
gerade 941 leute vor 41 minuten
in frage wegen dem super glide
autofahrer haben angekommen lauft
[Musik]
wir waren gerade schon draußen und haben
betroffene auch ein blue card nicht
dieser blaue ist jedoch die bühne und
mache challenges gegen zuschauer und der
verlierer bekommt eine kleine dusche
[Musik]
erst am 6 die kjg getränk mit super von
losfahren könnte achterbahn fahren
[Musik]
operation
[Applaus]
frage mein kamera
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die mich gerade
die zusage an der komplexität die
mitglied und verleitet wird so die
brücke gehört haben wir wohl noch vier
piloten gedacht
bastian und koko alle leute aufgeboten
wir machen jetzt eine stelle bei der die
platte auf dem boden auf dem die zwei
jungs mitte stehen lassen
jürgens bitte stehen lassen ist ja cool
dass die umwelt glaube das ziel vor
mit stefanie rist die duca - doch mit
ihm hat ja gar keinen job
die größte schlange
hallo leute nur gerne sagen
[Applaus]
auf instagram meine damen und herren wir
haben es geschafft fünf stunden
fünfeinhalb stunden autogramme gegeben
habe ja alles durchgekriegt wenn man
gesagt machen wir lieber irgendwie
anderthalb vier stunden länger als ein
paar leute einfach nicht bekommen dann
quasi vier stunden schlange stand und
danach nur gesagt bekomme hier bekommt
nur noch ein foto und die wollten
eigentlich noch eine spanne von freund
oder sie sind einfach dinge passiert
sind deswegen setze ich mich jetzt
einfach mal hier hin und landete mit
euch als nur die wahrheit war an diesen
events von 11 uhr morgens bis 18 uhr
haben versteht ich da wirklich falsch
und sich vor allem mega geil und ich
liebe einfach euch zu treffen und
einfach verstehen dass in jedem
einzelnen interview immer dass man was
wir da heute und personen und einzelne
menschen wirklich hinter den krieg
center stecken kriegen natürlich logisch
aber das ist mega cool einfach so die
echten gewicht dahinter bewegende welche
möglichkeiten ein bisschen teilzunehmen
eingeladen werde und dieses mal so dass
ich eigentlich als ps bekommen hat sich
irgendwie von jetzt.de nur bis 35 euro
gegeben also zweieinhalb stunden sondern
auf dem verein die welt angekommen und
das soll ja gesagt
letztendlich
1330 lokale ok das ist doch daran haben
mit nur noch eine halbe stunde mehr zeit
in der immer mehr leute durch kriegen
kann ihre verwaltung allerdings dass
alles werte lange gedauert hat also bei
mir immer wieder sich zu dem beginn von
treffen ich würde jedem mega lang
unterhalten
den ersten leuten bilder mache video auf
dem sprachnotizen unternahmen und
bleiben alle und sich persönlich darüber
zu geben dass der red bull muss man
solche mit jedem gleich viel zeit
verbringen oder mit auch man so viele
leute wie möglich halt irgendwie
schaffte glücklich machen kann hat er
jetzt endlich alles super geklappt und
wir haben alle durchgekriegt ihr
verhalten nur das habe ich auch eine
blockade da kontra sekunden paar minuten
haben dass wir hätten nicht von hier den
kurswechsel drei stangen gegeben haben
sondern um 13 uhr 30 betracht den reifen
fünfeinhalb stunden oder so alles in
allem nach löse klingen oder forberger
viele zuschauer nicht verstehen es
einfach man selber auch nur menschen
also ich bin keine maschine ich bin kein
wort über youtube aber das macht ja
nicht zu den menschen der ihnen die
kräfte aber keine normale menschen
bewusst sein oder in menschenkörper mehr
hatte ich werde mich nicht vernünftig
ausdrücke so dass man mich versteht aber
ich kann auch nicht irgendein als sechs
stunden aufgegeben und jagdzeit lächeln
und lagern und wohne
zwischendrin das essen und eine pause zu
machen wir wollten eine event jetzt also
mehrmals über vom januar läuft und
autogramme und kann wieder zwischendrin
heimat hause nehmen oder kunden gewesen
und so beinahe so viele leute da wir
keine zeit für eine pause hatten
ich hätte einfach zwischendurch weg
gehen können aber dann wären die leute
die einfach krank gewesen wären hätte
man einfach durchgehen müssen quasi
nicht getroffen
den wollte keine pause machen der bio
alles
bei drei stunden guten oder habe er
nicht mehr mit tieren von sechs stunden
am stück das sich einfach nicht bekommt
und bis dahin habe ich irgendwie 34
weintrauben und ein stück pet
dementsprechend war ich logischerweise
zu beginn der euphorisch und war mega
energie geladen und hatte richtig woche
machen angeblich in der letzten stunde
haben wir auch einige zuschauer gesagt
hat bei mir wirkt auch angesehen um
gewicht oder einfach fertig war
ich habe mich zwar werde häufig auch für
schuldig den report no alles so gut
gemacht ich konnte und ich weiß nicht ob
ich das gerade überhaupt benötigt
erkläre auch etwas versteht irgendwie um
objekte kommen ich habe mir einfach
gedacht hätte wäre ich jetzt eine pause
machen wenig praktizierten deutschen
väter brauchen kann noch einige merkel
nur freunde machen oder so regulieren
teilnehmen die daraus möglicherweise 20
minuten verspätung erstmals an der
stange vorbei gegangen wären an meinem
stand einfach content security weiter
gedrückt worden wären dass er auch
richtig ist damit einen wollen sich alle
stauden um stauffenberg in dieser zeit
durch eine pause gemacht hätte hätten
wir einfach locker 100 leute keine
bilder bekommen hätten möglichkeit im
wald angestanden hätten mich nicht
gesehen
mit ihr könnte man dann können sie nicht
treffen können und darf weil ich halt
vermeiden dass dinge ich habe dann er
gesagt okay ich lieber für die nächsten
stunden betrieb dollar machen kann das
nicht fassen 1000 leute halt nicht
bekommen bisher mit ermittler den
kommentaren ich bin ich überhaupt nicht
beschweren andere leute arbeiten jeden
tag acht stunden total hart und ich
meine ich bin einfach studenten bei
youtube videos macht aber ich wollte
euch das einfach erklären damit den
versteht die solche am ende sogar opa
und sollte das alles passieren lassen
und weiter im blog
ich bin gerade dieser zu hause
angekommen weg stunde ausgegeben und
noch mal zwei stunden autofahrt und
alles mögliche und jetzt schneide ich
sogar noch den blogger nicht in fünf
fahrer am ende einfach aber ich noch
wirklich sagen das komplette event war
oldschool beginn habe ich halt so mit
allen leuten typischer via romea lang
geredet und damit später gemerkt mit
markt weitere diana halt auch zusammen
das war leider dürfen wir zu dritt oder
zu viert autogramme geben das wir
zusammen straße machen aber zu mir und
dann prüfen wir ob man sie nicht in
unterhosen auf jeden fall gehe ich aber
ich habe mich bei den leuten bilder
gemacht und deswegen bin ich froh gerade
duschen doch nicht alle meinem blog
gegen jemanden grüßen die einmaligen
thema wenn du hier rein wie für ihr
schon die verpackung mobile toilette
dieser toilette blogge ich nicht immer
hey leute machen oder war auch die hier
gerade gesehen was trinken und ich würde
jetzt aber auch sagen freunde wenn
spricht gefallen hat die heutige welt
online a und block in die kommentare
[Musik]